hi everyone welcome back to LED life
have you noticed that the clothing
company make less clothing find out on
this episode of LED live hi everyone so
before we begin we want to thank our
patrons that make all of this possible
so if you haven't joined our patreon
family you can click the link below and
also don't forget to press like and
share this video to other people so in
today's topic we're gonna talk about
modesty I love it I love it before we
start though I want to tell you I'm very
excited to actually hear you present on
this topic because you know our patreon
donors and even people they message us
all the time and we actually recently
got a message they said hey we want to
see Michelle present one so here you go
back we do pay attention to what you
guys say and what you guys asked for so
yeah excited for this one okay so when
we talk about modesty usually people's
talking about what to wear and what not
to wear but it's actually more than that
what do you guys think the word modesty
means I think not bringing attention to
yourself you know what I mean like I
think you can be immodest not
necessarily just because you're showing
skin but I mean if I'm wearing like neon
green pants and exactly I can be just as
attention-seeking as somebody that's
wanting to show some skin yeah you fully
clothed I can be fully clothed and
immodest yes right right yeah so
according to merriam-webster dictionary
it says that modest modest the word
modest its observing the proprieties or
being appropriate of dress and behavior
interesting because I was thinking like
let me take a modest amount of mashed
potatoes or something like it
like not too much yeah but in clothing
it's think the opposite kind of like
lanes you can never have too much so and
also there's another meaning of modesty
according to merriam-webster it's like
you know what you say it's not excessive
not being too much just being simple
yeah it's not excessive but what the
Bible say about modesty where do you
guys find in the Bible thing of a modest
nurse it's about modest apparel right
yeah modest apparel III would say
probably in in the old Levitical laws
right I mean when they kind of like
talked about dress and how the people
should order themselves I think it's
also where we find or is it in the New
Testament that talks about the braided
hair yeah Timothy 2:9 yeah yeah so so
modesty I mean was obviously discussed
in the Old Testament but also discussed
in the New Testament Christian right
well explain that just because we might
not even talk about it and then they're
gonna be like wait I can't braid it here
what does that mean I'm gonna you're
gonna talk about it go to that first
yeah and yeah we usually if we are
talking about modesty we go to proverbs
31 verse 31 woman but that doesn't mean
modesty they it doesn't apply to guys to
it applies to everyone of all ages from
the youngest to the oldest so in
proverbs 31 it says in especially verses
25 and 30 it says strengths and honor
are her clothing and she shall rejoice
in time to come favor is deceitful and
beauty is vain but a woman that fears
the Lord she shall be praised I think
it's kind of like also taking the focus
off of the external because like it said
beauty comes and goes like what happens
if you get into a car accident yeah I
mean like all of a sudden if your world
is built around your looks your looks
can be swept away from you you get in a
fire you see people that have have had
you know terrible disasters happen to
them and it's like if your character is
not built on something more than that
and I could see that being the problem
so it's saying build it on you know your
foundation of your relationship with God
and your care right yeah so yeah modesty
is not just focusing on what we wear but
also our character and like in here it
says that you know sis
see a strong si s honor and most
importantly see fears the Lord so it's
not just see dress nice but she also
fears the Lord and that's what is
focusing here it's interesting like when
God created Adam and Eve and and I heard
this really awesome sermon on this one
time there was jewels all over the
ground
right precious stones that were part of
the creation that God had made yet he
scraped together the dust of the ground
and he formed Adam not using those
jewels and when you listen to the
description of how God designed
Lucifer in heaven right he filled all
these stones on and I mean this guy was
blinged out right so what was it that
God was doing by literally making us in
this very simplistic form not ordaining
us with this really flashy like thing I
think it was really because he was
wanting us to to focus on our curators
you know I mean yeah that's a good point
like you think about how this whole life
that we're playing out this whole
experience of life as a testimony one
day we're gonna look back and say this
is what happens when we rebel against
God's law he's got some kind of perfect
system that were supposed to follow and
and sin will never rise a second time
because we've had the experience so you
can also look at that like like you said
look what happens when you create
someone with all these beautiful jewels
you could say why don't you make me out
of jewels how come I was made out of the
dust well look what happens pride all
this stuff you know I thought God in His
perfect wisdom I'm going to create Adam
out of the dust of the ground and you
know what to say those who lift
themselves up will be like a little
brother yeah
like the first will be last and all that
God praises humility that's why it says
like you know the the the meek they will
inherit the kingdom of God
you know the humble that you can
constantly see this thread of God
wanting you to to have this humility and
approach and I think when we're so
focused on the outside adornment well we
look like you know and that trumps who
we really are
right yeah and if we see in Genesis
before sin came to the world they didn't
even know that they were naked yeah but
when the sin came to the world and they
started to pay attention to themselves
they started to cover it himself
yeah so let's see what the word modest
in the Bible so we take a look from his
to Bible verse in 1st Timothy 2:9 and
1st Timothy 3:2 in the first Timothy 2:9
the word modest is cosmos in Greek and
in 1st Timothy 3:2 the word good
behavior is also the same Kazmir's and
cause mios yeah interesting I think of
the magazine college I don't know what's
the connection with that but it's just
interesting that in I know in 1st
Timothy 2:9 it's talking about you know
women has to close in modest apparel and
in 1st Timothy 3:2 is talking about the
priests you know the leader the men that
he has to be good behavior have to a
good behavior so modesty is also related
with your good behavior and the priest
right they wore white throughout the
year right it was only it was only on
the day of atonement or was the other
way around it was the high priest on the
Day of Atonement wore only white were
only white yeah but the rest of the year
he wore his regalia was the most simple
thing he could come to the Lord in yeah
sackcloth yeah on the most important
Jewish day like that that'll did to kind
of tell you right there what's what's in
Borden mm-hmm so yeah for people or guys
they usually think modesty doesn't know
you know I feel today bye to them but
well your behavior is also part of your
modesty hmmmm thank you bringing
attention to yourself I mean you think
of like where God is wanting to lead his
people right to have and reflect his
character right and what is the
character of Jesus life what's the
character of God like right he was very
humble meek he did not have anything he
was not physically beautiful so to say
that people should worship Him and adore
him just because of that it was it was
really the when they met him they were
like wow there's something different
about this guy it was all others focused
what you that illustration you gave
about you know if you get a car wreck or
a fire you know that that's really deep
to think about because look at some of
the most beautiful women that walk into
any place and manager so hey let me buy
you a drink or let me oh I'll buy you
anything you want I'll give you this
dress or whatever they're looking at the
external beauty and and that can get a
lot but if you don't have it then where
does that go now a sudden you're just
any old person and if you had a great
personality though it wouldn't matter
people would be like oh I love to hang
out with this person you know they're
there so others focused I want to give
to them because they're so giving but if
all you're doing is receiving receiving
receiving because of your beauty and you
lose it you got nothing left just like
the trophy wife or whatever but no
personality do you guys know who Val
Kilmer is yeah okay you name a movie
that Val Kilmer was in hey okay any
other ones you think you but the Saint
the saint okay man yeah what's fun it's
one of the real famous ones airplane op
gun Top Gun he was a Top Gun right so
he's this good-looking guy right you
know Val Kilmer is know Wow we're gonna
show you a picture of Al Kilmer now this
is Michelle's first alright did you know
that Val Kilmer had throat cancer and
all of a sudden like you haven't seen
anything from him in Hollywood Hollywood
totally distance himself from him I
think I I read this post that he was
like working as a
and he was describing how lonely his
life was nobody want anything to do with
him he wasn't invited to any of these
parties wasn't you know nobody's asking
to take his picture anymore he looks
totally different and he was literally
saying he has like literally one friend
and I remember in the article just kind
of shocked me and it's like yeah man you
can be on the top of this world so to
say where everybody thinks they want you
I'm assuming that's what a female feels
like right you walk into the room if
you're beautiful and everybody's like
wanting your number or whatever
yeah but then if that beauty is taken
away from you what do you have right you
know what I mean yeah so yeah right now
I'm going to that first that you were
saying you know that's actually in first
Peter 3 3 to 4 who saw our dawning let
it not be that outward adorning by
plating hair and stuff like that but let
it be hidden man of the heart and it
continues in that which is not
corruptible even the ornament of a meek
and quiet spirit which is in the sight
of God of great price Wow you know I
think historically the reason why they
didn't want them to braid the hair was
the amount of time it took if I can
remember correctly I think I was
remember looking into this at one point
in time and it was like they spent an
incredible amount of time doing these
kind of things and so it was like you
know I I could imagine it would be like
today
how long do women really spend getting
ready mmm I mean how long do you spend
getting ready be on defense they just
show you have to tell the truth I can't
get right in 15 minutes that's pretty
good some women take hours hours and you
know what's mind-boggling to me about
that is you think about it right they
take hours to get prepared in the
morning and you go well how long did you
study this morning mmm how long did you
spend with God all right I don't got the
time I don't got the time I got two
minutes right but really you can spend
an hour getting ready but you don't have
that time to spend with God I mean think
about that
and I think that's kind of the the the
context of what this was saying as well
as I think they were spending an
incredible amount of time on their own
selves where it was like you know you
should be spending time on your right in
the in the last part of first Peter 5:5
actually says that God resisteth the
proud and gives grace to the humble so
God doesn't like proud heart he always
wants us to be humble in humility and
like that so I think it's character so I
think it's safe to say that being modest
according to the Bible is more of God
and less of self okay being selfless and
more focused on God but doesn't mean we
have to neglect our outside appearance
doesn't mean we have to dress inside
claws and ugly claws what do you guys
think no I mean you know I I like you
know very nice clothing I don't a little
white t-shirt we're trying to actually
use the t-shirts as as a witness so it's
really a sort of conversation starter
yeah because people do notice it right
if you have a really neat interesting
design on your shirt and somebody goes
man I really like that shirt you know
I'm like wow it's got a Bible verse on
it you're bringing attention to that I
think that that's kind of in in my eyes
if I can divert people's minds to God or
to something greater than us mm-hmm
that's very good way to look at it cuz
if you know bringing attention to
yourself someone might say oh you bring
attention to yourself no I'm bringing
attention to this verse whereas you
might say wow look at your whatever
drawn attention to some part of your
body instead of the verse the Bible
verse so Mikey you used to own a
clothing company yeah right so what do
you notice that's different about the
way that you would do your clothing
company as opposed to even the way that
we deal with our t-shirt stuff I guess
the target audience say I I designed the
clothes to look like a rock band shirt
or like a skater thing and that's not
necessarily bad itself but I mean one of
the shirts was a Medusa head a severed
Medusa head and
skulls this this tattoo is actually the
the logo for the brand so I mean that
was on there and yeah I was just like
what are you actually glorifying what
are you glamourizing it was nothing
about God and and over time when when
God you know transformed my heart I was
trying to veer that clothing line I just
to say this I had models and bands from
all over the world literally Spain
California Australia everywhere wearing
this clothing line and then I started
trying to veer it to a Christian
direction and nobody was aware many more
so because of the this sort of the group
that you were speaking to so it was like
that group probably did not identify
with Christian it was all models which
is alternative models who would send
pictures wearing basically just the
shirt and then you'd have bands or metal
bands wearing it on stage and they're
not trying to rock Jesus or a cross or
whatever so yeah it's just the target
audience which is why it was such a cool
thing to get to collab with little light
and use their audience to to be able to
share the gospel and shirts like that
this is one thing I can't like a bring
out in our in our comments will have
people like oh you're trying to profit
off the Word of God but if you don't put
a verse on there then they're like well
where's the Bible verse we're not trying
to profit off the Word of God the shirts
cost money and it helps the ministry and
we want to offer people a way to witness
by wearing your shirt and I actually
love it when I see somebody with a Bible
verse on their t-shirt I immediately
assume something about that person and
that's not yeah when you see somebody
out in public and they've got some kind
of Christian thing and it's like oh wow
they're Christian yeah inside Club and I
feel this like a little bit of a bond
with them or or whatever right and and
and you know it's interesting because I
spent time in Hollywood okay so the the
the place is teeming with beautiful
people people who don't wear much
clothing you know and then since I got
married and came out
life and I've really spent my time in
the ministry world you know you kind of
think that's normal and then you kind of
get around a bunch of people who do
dress modestly or are not you know
following all the latest and greatest
trends or something and then it's all of
a sudden you go near one of those cities
or you go back to around some of those
people and it's like whoa yeah like I
can't believe they put that like out
there I mean when you go to LA they have
billboards in LA of girls literally
naked like side profile and it's like
how rude is this I mean there's lots of
kids in cars and things going by but
that's just normal to them and so when
you when you when you see that all the
time I think then you value the external
nobody's driving by seeing that naked
person and going I wonder if she has a
really nice heart right you don't think
that that's not what's on your mind
mm-hmm
yeah and also you know even the proverb
says that this woman see dress in silk
and purple and you know purple is a
symbol of royalty so when we dress we
need to thing you know how can we dress
as a royal member of the kingdom of God
and talking about sometimes I've heard
this that you know being modest you have
to dress you know like ugly clothes you
know like dark colors or a dull color
well I think somehow if you dress like
that so ugly so different from the world
you also bring attention to yourself
that's true hippies that claim that they
don't care about fashion that's a
fashion the grunge yeah old flannel they
care about their clothing probably a lot
more than you think they do yeah I want
to think about Tommy so my brother my
brother yeah take away his hat or
something
bless Tom's heart I love my love my
brother but he you know he he was born
in the wrong decade he should have been
born in the 70s
and you know but he's got his own little
style in his own little you know he was
born in the seventies I did this thing I
have some experience we with like this
dress and the way we dress and how
people around you treat you so I went to
a touristic place in Indonesia so on the
first day on this one day I was dressing
you know pretty good and a lot of and
then we got lost we were trying to find
a restaurant but then we got lost to the
street where there's a lot of club and
bars and everything and that day a lot
of people like offer or do you want here
do you want to get in we have promotion
but I just walk straight the next day I
went to the same place to get something
but I was in my pajamas it was that
night nobody offer to get for me to get
into the bar or anything interesting
social experiment right yeah right yeah
so and being modest is not about just
respecting ourselves
I like the billboard that you were
talking about it's about respecting
people around us and just imagine if
you're addressing really many with
meaning everything and then you go to a
place where there is a lot of children
how do you guys feel as a parents with
your children seeing those people
dressing like that
and the kids notice it like my daughter
mentions it when she sees somebody
that's a really dressy risque or
something like this show mom did you see
what that girls wearing you know what I
mean so you know it's it's people do
notice all right yeah that's making me
think of the verse that talks about not
causing a brother to stumble or whatever
like yeah it's not a victimless crime
you you walk around with your cleavage
busting out it's not that every man is a
pervert it's I mean you're we're Gossard
we're wired like that yeah that's right
that's not supposed to be seen and
and now it is it's like you're causing
this man to stumble right and I also I
was listening to this podcast by Leslie
Ludi if you guys haven't heard about her
she's a Christian author and she talks
about a lot about this beauty modesty
relationship and that kind of stuff so
she say in her podcast about modesty
that being modest means not exposing
what should not be exposed have a
dignity and honor to our body like our
body is sacred
it's the land full of God you know how
there's like a ton of parallels to God's
creation and then some sort of deep
spiritual truth I don't get kind of
graphic here a little bit hopefully our
audience is mature and can handle this
but if you just study the sanctuary
message right you have the priest who's
literally only able to come into the
most holy place he's the only one to
come into the most holy place and in our
relationship in our marriage is right we
are the priests and there are places
that we are the only ones that are
allowed into that space and so you know
it's it's very interesting when you kind
of like look at how even just the
relationship between a man and a woman
is set up and it's like there's such a
deep spiritual truth right there that
yeah I mean we should be protecting that
area yeah if we could just understand
the true holiness the God ordained it to
be it wouldn't be so cheap and like
house one-night stand or whatever like
wow really
that's like slaughtering a pig on the
altar or something like right as well
yeah and also it's for women and also
men and for the singles especially being
modest is also respecting your future
husband right just imagine you know you
guys are married but imagine if before
you married you can see what your spouse
is doing do you want her to you have
interaction with the opposite sex in
like a flirty way or sensual way I'm
pretty sure it's gonna feel
uncomfortable for you right very true
thank you
yeah from start to finish you have to
think about it I mean even as a young
child even a teenager you know their
husband or wife is we're running around
out there you know that is so true and
the decisions that you make even then in
your dress can impact you know down the
road all right so if we think of our
body as a temple of God we want to keep
it always nice we always want to adorn
it too with something that is a part of
the Royal member of kingdom of God but I
also believe that doesn't mean to be
modest we have to buy cheap clothing if
we can afford durable more pricier
clothing right but still on our budget
I'm pretty sure that's being modest too
if my budget allowed I would love to buy
Patagonia everything I can't afford that
yeah like you said you know it'll hold
up better yeah really like cheap things
do fall apart there's there's some
things where it's just a brand it
doesn't matter it's it's just a image or
whatever but some things really cost
more because they hold up longer and
that's really being logical about well
these pants will last me three years or
whatever that's really the best enough
yeah and another question also do you
think being modest can we follow fashion
[Music]
totally out of touch with that world now
I know fashion is always pushing the
envelope I watched this video of this
Victoria's Secret model that had stopped
being a Victoria's Secret models gonna
bring that up I was gonna wait for like
a we should we should we should show a
couple clips from her if you have some
but I'll just quickly tell real quick I
mean it was really amazing and she
talked about the history of why why we
like skinny women fashionably what
likewise and it came from the fashion
designers were all males and yet they
were all pretty much homosexual males
and they liked homosexual male type boys
body type and so they were choosing
women that fit that body type which was
skinny
you know ii mean but not a voluptuous
well I'm just yeah and where they did
studies where they actually found that
we are actually more azzam as a male
species we are more attracted to a curvy
type of woman and you know it's
interesting how those those patterns
have changed over the years but that's
that's where the whole skinny thing came
from right yeah so I think it's okay if
we are following fashion but there's a
but we are not being slave to fashion
and we really need to look through it
not just accepting all fashion if the
fashion is like wearing super crop crop
top no we're not supposed to follow it
but if it's you know like a like a nice
modest dress or for guys and I shared
nice pants that is not really too tight
you know there's some guys that wear
pants there is so tight yeah so yeah I
think it's fine because like I've
mentioned before that doesn't mean we
neglect outside appearance because if
we're in 2020 if we're dressing like
1920 we're gonna get people to pay
attention to us too this is true all
right so you want to say something I've
noticed that when people say like
Hollywood doesn't affect them or them he
didn't affect them I'm like look at
trends you know look at how everybody's
dressed this certain way why because
some Hollywood celebrity award in a
music video or whatever it made it look
cool now
now masses of people are following this
because of one person did it you know
the only thing that comes to mind right
now like Kanye West the the shutter
shades own if you remember those those
things are out in the 80s right all of a
sudden everybody wanted to buy my worked
at Hot Topic and we sold them in every
form and fashion and everybody wanted
them at that time period because Kanye
made look cool and it's just like do you
really think it looks cool are you
wearing this because you think it looks
cool or well this is what's cool because
Kanye wore in a video and it could
almost make a mockery of you know I
could just say somehow it was celebrity
like let's see if everybody follow this
wears some big afro wig or something now
everybody's wearing that
respects me wonder so let me ask the
question about this what do you guys
think about yoga pants hmm it's like
everywhere everyone wearing them all the
time I mean there you literally have you
know no imagination of what those kirk's
leave me like leggings yes like the
popular thing to wear what you see I
mean even even young kids it's like they
want to wear like those kind of
clothings and that's what's out there in
the world right now so you know yeah you
can see how those trends kind of get out
in yeah it's like you we only have we
don't sew our own clothing so I mean we
really get to buy what's on the market
you go to Walmart if suddenly Walmart
doesn't sell jeans anymore we oh we're
so leggings right and yeah you know that
I want to bring this up that for us
women by being modest we can also teach
guy to be a gentleman I'm all right yes
because if we don't even respect
ourselves how can we expect guys to
respect us you know guys really want
that I think they really want a modest
girl because you know you get married
you don't want to be thinking wow my
girl did that with me so she could do
that with other people you know and so
you know I think deep down inside I
think the lie that girls believe is that
if I dress like this they'll really want
me oh really I think deep down inside oh
you don't want that kind of guy first of
all if you really likes that type of
girl you want the type of guy that that
really appreciates you for who you are
when they're talking to you they're
looking at your eyes you know no you're
not just like scanning up and down right
yeah cuz you know you hear a lot of
these girls coming like oh yeah there's
the guys in this timer but they're just
a pervert but well think again what are
what they wear when you try to meet that
guy and you wear a bikini or do you
cover your body right so it depends on
them yeah so like if you're
a guy looking for a girl and yeah
have you ever heard where people say
like well that's the type of girl I
would date but not the type of girl I'd
marry yeah well yeah whatever you want
to be that girl is not marriage material
Yeah right so in closing they're just
some few question that we should ask
ourselves every time we are dressing or
we act certain way am i reflecting our
natural beauty that god's given us or we
are reflecting sensual beauty mm-hmm
mm-hmm
am i reflecting light or am i reflecting
darkness am i respecting others around
me that I will come in contact with it's
important not to try to focus on our
outside appearance first Gustad will be
hard if we have to think every day
whether we should wear these or do this
or do that if we just start by fearing
the Lord with our heart everything will
come natural all right
and a little illustration before we
close when we buy a nice iPad a nice
phone we put cover on it right so it's
the same thing with our body we are made
in the image of God so we want to take
care of our body in the way we conduct
ourselves in the way we cover ourselves
I don't like the feeling of a naked
phone that's a good illustration so
thank you for watching and don't forget
to leave like and comment and subscribe
to our Channel and also share if you
have something else that you have you
want us to talk about you can put it in
a comment and we will try to do it thank
you see you next week
[Music]